What's up movie connoisseurs?
Do you think you know everything there is
to know about the weird and wonderful world
of cinema?
Do you like testing that knowledge and bragging
to your friends about it?
Well then, this is the video for YOU!
Welcome to the Screen Rant Ultimate Movie
Quiz.
If you can get all 10 of these questions right,
then you can consider yourself a serious movie
buff!
Keep your score as you go and then leave it
in the comment section below, no lying!
Let’s begin!
Jared Leto is currently starring as The Joker
in Suicide Squad, but he wasn't the first
actor that Warner Brothers sought out for
the role.
Do you know which leading man was the initial
choice?
A - Matt Damon
B - Jim Carrey
(Screen lights up C)
While Matt Damon has been heavily linked to
being given a role in the DC Extended Movie
Universe, and while Jim Carrey would undoubtedly
make a very interesting version of The Joker,
it was Ryan Gosling who was the first choice
for the role.
However, the star of The Notebook wasn't willing
to sign on for the multi-picture deal that
the studio was requiring.
The screenplay for 2016's remake of The BFG
was written by the late Melissa Mathison and
the movie itself was directed by Steven Spielberg.
But which movie had the pair collaborated
on in this fashion before?
A - A.I.
Artificial Intelligence
B - Indiana Jones and the Temple of Doom
C - E.T. the Extra-Terrestrial
(Screen lights up C)
Prior to The BFG, the last movie to have its
screenplay written by Melissa Mathison and
be directed by Steven Spielberg was E.T. the
Extra-Terrestrial.
It was the highest-grossing movie of 1982
and if that success can be anywhere near emulated
by The BFG, it will be considered a huge success.
Pretty much everybody knows that Heath Ledger
won a postumous Oscar for his portrayal of
The Joker in The Dark Knight, but the film
also earned numerous other nominations at
the 81st Academy Awards.
Do you know how many it was nominated for
in total?
A – 7
B - 8
C - 9
(Screen lights up B)
The Dark Knight was actually nominated for
a total of 8 Academy Awards, making it the
comic book movie with the highest number of
nominations to date.
The categories it was nominated for were Best
Supporting Actor and Best Sound Editing - both
of which it won - Best Sound Mixing, Best
Art Direction, Best Cinematography, Best Makeup,
Best Film Editing and Best Visual Effects.
The Avengers, like most other major movies,
had a pre-production working title that enabled
Marvel Studios to keep the project under wraps
until they wanted the world to know about
it.
But what was that working title?
A - Group Hug
B - Come Together
C - Family Affair
(Screen lights up A)
As revealed in an interview by Loki himself,
Tom Hiddleston, prior to the movie's production
- and even in the early stages of filming
- The Avengers was referred to as "Group Hug".
It would later be released to theatres under
the name "Team Building".
After the title of the upcoming Rogue One:
A Star Wars story was revealed, Lucasfilm
were threatened with a potential lawsuit to
change the name out of fear of audiences confusing
it with which other movie?
A – Rogue
B - Operation Rogue
C - Mission: Impossible - Rogue Nation
(Screen lights up C)
It was Paramount who made the threat, relating
to their 2015 movie Mission: Impossible - Rogue
Nation, even though the two movies were set
for release more than a year apart.
However, the two studios came to an agreement
that Rogue One could keep its name on the
condition that information about it wasn't
released until after Rogue Nation had hit
theatres.
The music for Star Wars: The Force Awakens
was, of course, composed by the legendary
John Williams.
For J.J. Abrams, this marked the first occasion
that a movie he directed wasn't being scored
by a certain other composer.
But who had provided the score for his other
movies?
A - Michael Giacchino
B - Ludovico Einaudi
C - J.J. Abrams himself
(Screen lights up A)
American composer Michael Giacchino is the
man who provided the music for every movie
J.J. Abrams had directed up until The Force
Awakens.
These included Mission: Impossible III, Cloverfield,
Star Trek and Super 8.
The upcoming Harry Potter series spin-off
Fantastic Beasts and Where to Find Them will
be set predominantly in New York.
However, it was filmed in England, so which
former Royal Air Force base doubled as New
York's docks during production?
A - R.A.F. Buckminster
B - R.A.F. Cardington
C - R.A.F. Carlisle
(Screen lights up B)
R.A.F. Cardington will double as New York's
docks in the J.K.
Rowling-penned production.
Located in Bedfordshire, the base boasts a
long and varied history, particularly in relation
to airships and balloons.
Chris Evans is always in great shape when
he portrays Captain America in the Marvel
Cinematic Universe and he looked particularly
good portraying the titular character in Captain
America: Civil War, but do you know how the
film-makers made him look even more muscular
than he really was in the final movie?
A - CGI augmentation
B - He wore T-shirts that were too small
C - He was forced to pump iron seconds before
filming every scene
(Screen lights up B)
Costume designer Judianna Makovsky has revealed
that for all of Chris Evans's scenes in which
he wore civilian clothing, the T-shirts he
wore were purposely several sizes too small,
which made it look as though his muscles were
truly huge and bulging.
A lot of 2015's Inside Out took place inside
the main character Riley Andersen's mind.
In her mind, there was a functioning TV studio
called Dream Productions.
In order to depict Dream Productions, Inside
Out's writers visited a member of the movie's
cast on one of his TV shows to see how it
all worked.
Which cast member was it?
A - Bill Hader
B - Kyle MacLachlan
C - Lewis Black
(Screen lights up A)
To see how a working TV studio operated, Inside
Out's writers visited Bill Hader on the set
of Saturday Night Live, which is located at
Studio 8H on floors 8 and 9 of the Comcast
Building in New York City.
Popular composer Hans Zimmer, who composed
the score for DC movies Man of Steel, Batman
v Superman: Dawn of Justice, and The Dark
Knight Trilogy, has stepped down from composing
movie scores in the superhero business and
will not be composing the score for Justice
League.
But who will be?
A - John Williams
B - Junkie XL
C - Danny Elfman
(Screen lights up B)
It will be Junkie XL, the Dutch composer who
assisted Hans Zimmer with the score for Batman
v Superman: Dawn of Justice, who will compose
the score for the Justice League movie.
His other work includes Mad Max: Fury Road
and Deadpool.
Thanks for watching and for taking part in
our first behind the scenes movie facts quiz.
Did you enjoy this video?
How well did you do with the questions?
Leave your score in the comment section below
and don’t forget to subscribe to our channel
for more fun videos like this one!